hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast detection and sequencing rare
mutations using mutation enrichment in a
cold pcr I'm Brenda Kelly Kim with lab
rats I'll be your moderator for today's
event this webcast is presented by lab
rats calm the leading social media site
for science professionals and provider
webinars for we start there are a few
extractions you want to hear from you
during this broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment answers
are welcome to you can do this by
hitting a green Q&A button lower left of
the presentation window and type in your
comments in on the screen that appears
we'll try to get to as many of your
questions as we can if we don't have
time today we'll follow up with you via
email water better look you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
definitely let us know by clicking on
the support button in the top right or
use the Q&A button lower left we'll make
sure to try and resolve any issues
additionally we'd like you to know that
this presentation has been approved for
continuing education credits if you want
to obtain your credits please click on
your get your free CEC emmy credits
button located in the lower left of your
screen this will take you to a page
listing all of our presentations and
speakers please select the appropriate
CEC md button for your presentation and
follow the instructions to claim your
certificate now let's get right to
today's presenter we are proud to
welcome dr. Mike Murphy Orville's dr.
mario goes is a professor of radiation
oncology and director of the Medical
Physics and biophysics division a
dana-farber cancer institute Brigham and
Women's hospitals Harvard Medical School
he also directs the DNA technology
laboratory and the radiation preclinical
facility his research interests include
the development of a novel DNA
technologies for molecular diagnostics
in oncology and the identification of
circulating cancer biomarkers for more
information about his background and
experience please click on dr. Murphy
your doses name
alternate over to Mike for his
presentation Thank You Brenda for the
introduction vendor thank you for the
introduction and good evening everybody
today we are going to talk about how we
can detect rare mutations that is
mutations that are at a low level
compared to why type using mutation
enrichment via called PCR methodology so
there are many cases where we have a low
number of minor alleles minor DNA
alleles in an excess of why type alleles
other than cancer one example is
prenatal diagnosis where we are
interested to find genotypes coming
specifically from the fetus diluted in
mother's blood another situation is in
infectious diseases we want to see early
detection of resistant strains new
genotypes and merging the population of
drug responsive strains and of course in
the field of cancer where we are focused
alarm main our main direction has been
to find ways to enrich the rare
mutations that are found in cancer
samples in many different situations
like when you have them as you can see
here on the top left pancreatic
infiltrating adenocarcinoma there is no
way that the biopsy will not also pick
up some wild type cells in addition to
the cells of interest the mutated cancer
cells or in many other cases lung
cancers are known to be fairly
heterogeneous or samples obtained from
surgical margins or for following at
your chemotherapy or DNA equal
acted from bodily fluids from plasma
plasma circulating DNA for example so in
many of these cases you have a low
number of mutation containing alleles
that contain useful information for for
the patient these mutations can be
predictive prognostic and can give us
them a good assessment of what is
happening in the particular patient
cancer for example but we have the
technical problem that there is a very
low number of mutant alleles diluted in
wild-type Alice so many different many
papers or in recent years have
highlighted this problem of intratumoral
heterogeneity and one of these papers is
this this paper in new zealand journal
of medicine the demonstrated that there
is a high in that human heterogeneity
and branched evolution as revealed by a
multi-region sequencing in particular
and many different portions of this
tumor sample were individually sequenced
and the authors demonstrated that there
is a variety of mutations from different
parts of the tumor that the standard
poor biopsy would probably not pick
since aboard biopsy would select only to
test only part of this office tumor in
addition metastatic sites can have
different mutations and that that brings
a number of conceptual and technical
problems and for for cancer diagnosis
the conceptual problem is how much we
believe a biopsy if we get a certain
answer about the existence of chaos
mutations for example
could it be that we are missing part of
the tumor that has a careless negative
cash positive mutation and therefore
there would be an indication for a
different type of treatment and it
interesting it is living however these
mutations can be detected in plasma in
many cases so DNA from cells that are
undergoing apoptosis or necrosis due to
the tumor evolution process or do tomb
and the treatment can release their DNA
in the plasma in the bloodstream and
then with them standard blood collection
one can collect his DNA that contains
information about the tumor so a lot of
diagnostic prognostic and predictive
information can be detected by
collecting this DNA from the tumor in
the plasma of course that drinks now the
technical problem how do you detect the
mutation containing DNA when it is
diluted with DNA coming from many other
normal tissues in the plasma so again
low level mutations are difficult to
identify especially when their position
on the sequence is unknown for example
when one is looking for p53 mutations
that can be anywhere along an applicant
or a long gene it is more difficult to
identify them so today we will talk for
our solution to this problem by which we
magnify unknown mutations in given
amplicon by a technique known as called
PCR called PCR was originally developed
back in two thousand eight and then
through the years and number of
refinements appropriate for different
situations have appeared the ice called
PCR in nucleic acids research the
temperature tolerant called PCR clinical
chemistry and Maury
the digital called PCR so in the in the
next 40 minutes we will go through each
one of these embodiments of cold vision
and explain what is their use and how
can one can gain information by applying
them so the general principle which the
technique is based them is simply the
biophysics of melting and rishabh
realization of the DNA the DNA melting
temperature known as TM is dependent on
DNA sequence so DNA fragments differing
even by a single nucleotide over say 200
base pair amplicon can have
substantially different denaturation
efficiency at certain critical
denaturalization temperatures this
observation is exploited during cold
vision as you will see in the next slide
so here is the principle we start by the
nature in DNA at 94 degrees and then
introducing within the PCR cycling and
intermediate temperature for example 75
degrees during this intermediate
hybridization temperature the primers do
not bind because they are designed to
bind at lower temperatures way below 60
65 degree so a temperature of 75 degrees
has the effect that only the original
amplicons can read hybridize back and
the primers do not bind when the
original amplicons hybridize back what
happens is that a potential mutation
containing amplicon will hybridize with
wild-type
containing and DNA forming a
heteroduplex as well as many homo
duplexes hetero duplexes are known to
have in almost all cases lower
denaturation temperature TM the TM of
the heteroduplex obtained from a mutant
and wild-type amplicon is lower than
very homo duplex the wild-type homo
duplex so we introduce a small
difference which can be point three
point four degrees difference between
mutants and nonmutants amplicons and in
the next step we increase the
temperature to a critical
denaturalization temperature that allows
only the hetero duplexes or i should say
preferentially the federal duplexes to
denature so here you can see the
preferential denaturing of mutations of
mutant mutation containing hetero
duplexes while the white type homo
duplicates remain substantially
double-stranded ones will have denatured
the hetero duplexes we now reduce the
temperature so that the primers can bind
and replicate selectively those strands
that contained the mutation and then we
start over go to the next cycle of pcr
and do this process again in the game
what what is important to realize is
that by doing this process will create
that there are duplexes irrespective at
any position of the amplicon so no
matter what type of mutation one has or
we're on the amplicon the mutation is
there will always be a heteroduplex
created and as a result this will have a
generally lower the naturalization
temperature
the homo duplex so the process the
enrichment process by Cole pcl will
occur irrespective of where the mutation
needs and what type of mutation of
course the amount of enrichment after 25
psychosis pcr will be different from
mutation to mutation but in every case
there will be some enrichment as you
will see later on this process is
reasonably quantitative and one can
predict what the enrichment is going to
be so this is the tryn supplant weeds
called PCR works so the next and next
development that we called improved and
complete enrichment courtyard or ice
called PCR involve the introduction of a
sequence which matters the Y type
reference sequence here is a reference
sequence we add an excess of reference
sequences that have the Y type and
sequence in the reaction and you may ask
of course why add wild type in the
reaction the wild type is what you want
to get rid of and while this sequence is
designed in such a way that it will not
amplify during pcr the three prime end
has been terminated terminated in such a
way that the polymerase will not extend
it so the only thing that this reference
sequence is going to do during pcr is to
help the formation of hetero duplexes in
the early stages of PCR but mutant
stunts and wild-type strands are low
number of copies and it is more
difficult to form the heteroduplex so in
the first ten cycles of pcr when you are
starting from low numbers of DNA or from
genomic DNA
this hetero duplexing which is required
during pcr is more difficult to form
there is no the kinetics of the reaction
don't work out so by adding this white
type reference sequence at an excess
compared to the original DNA we help the
formation of a heteroduplex asst in Adly
phases of the reaction so this is the
only difference from the principle that
you saw in the previous slide so I
scored PCR encode PCR are essentially
the same principle except that ice
called Rigga employees reference
sequence that helps the reaction proceed
at the early stages of PCR so these are
the principles so before we solve some
results one can point out that one can
use coal pcr an ice-cold pcr essentially
in every method that uses pcr prior to
mutation detection so PC on is used
prior to many different methods one
could say almost every method toyota
mutation detection pcr followed by
Sanger sequencing has been the classical
historical way tool to identify
mutations pcr followed by him HR melting
is a very popular mutation scanning
method that people are utilizing these
days a lot again you are starting with
pcr digital PCR is another way by which
people detect mutations and even many
many embodiments of massively parallel
sequencing amplicon sequencing or
targeted resequencing very often employs
pcr
so in all of these cases if one replaces
pcr with cole pcr he will get a boost in
sensitivity and the remainder of the
stop you will see a combination of coal
pcr with some of the methods that we
discussed aids are melting Sanger
sequencing DD pcr and massively parallel
sequencing so here is an example of
applying cold pcr in the place of pcr
when it is followed by sanger sequencing
and these are some of our original
results you can see here that if you if
you employ regular pc are followed by
thanking sequence you can only see a
very small amount of mutation which one
wonders if it is simply noise but if one
applies call pc on the mutation becomes
very obvious the sample is essentially
heterozygous here after enrichment
vehicle pcr and of course in the early
stages of the technology until we make
sure that the results are our robust we
we used to verify with an independent
method all of these mutations but we saw
in clinical samples in the in the second
row you can see a mutation detected in
plasma plasma circulating DNA from one
of our radiation therapy patients and in
the bottom slide you can see mutations
that are detected in ffb tissue so in
other words one can apply Kohl pcr in
any case but pcr used to be employed
whether it is for for snap frozen
samples like the top one or plasma
circulating DNA like a second one or
FFPE samples formalin-fixed samples
and of course one wonders what happens
if after the first PC first called PCR
13 dilutes the sample and does a second
call this year well as you as you can
expect the overall enrichment increases
even more by a second round of cod
vision so in this worker that we
reported in 2009 by in human mutation we
demonstrated this point as you can see a
first called PCR did not find a mutation
in this particular case it was a very
low level mutation but with a second
call busy on with the second round of
coal pcr the mutation becomes obvious we
do not recommend a third round of cod
VCR or a fourth round because eventually
pcr generated errors polymerase
generated errors will start appearing
creating and in reading noise which will
appear as false mutations but up to two
rounds of coal pcr the results are still
clearly distinguishable from polymerase
errors and what you see here is in the
application of ice called PCR in
conjunction with Ellen a locked nucleic
acids so the reference sequence that I
described earlier on is used for i scorn
pcr here has embedded locked nucleic
acids to increase the delta TM the
difference between heteroduplex and homo
duplex which is created during pcr as a
result you get a much bigger enrichment
with a single pcr application of
ice-cold pcr and what you see here in
this slide is serial dilution
of a mutation containing sequencer be
rough v600e mutation and you can see
that the limit of sensitivity is 0.05 to
0.02 percent in this case this data has
been provided to us by Catherine
Richardson and was reported in the Oscar
2011 and they have been actually
developed them by trans anomic which is
the company that has licensed the
technology from the dana-farber from my
institution and here again you see
detection of Bill of mutations in
melanoma from ffpe teasers independently
from our group the group of York toaster
in France has developed another version
of ice called this year which with the
very deadly they named the e is called
visual essentially again with ease and I
sculpey reality blows Ellen aids in
strategic special positions placed a
longer the reference sequence used in
ice-cold vision and they have reported
similar sensitivities to what you see
here what about quantification in other
words after you enrich the original
mutation by ice called PCR or cold this
year you can easily see it in sequencing
or by HRM or any other but can you
relate back to the original mutation
evidence and this is an important
question because it is the original
mutation evidence not just the presence
of the mutation that ideally we would
like to identify in many cases the
original evidence of the mutation but we
find in plasma is
clinically useful indicator so we try to
sing if by using standard curves we can
relate the final mutation evidence to
the original mutation evidence and as
you can see here the task can be
accomplished to within a certain extent
so it is not strictly quantitative but
at least semi quantitative what you see
here is many different mutations diluted
serially and by using is called visual
we draw a straight line reasonably
straight line within the data points
independent of what type of mutation we
have so the answer to whether we can do
quantitation is that within twenty to
thirty percent one can quantify the
original mutation evidence by looking at
the final mutation evidence so the
method is not as quantitative as one
would get with methods like digital PCR
for example but it is reasonably well
quantitative for most clinical
applications and here is an example of
quantitation with is called vision that
has clinical significance so to the
question of what level of mutations is
clinically significant but people often
asked us well that depends on the
particular clinical situation and in
this particular situation we wanted to
see what is the clinically significant
threshold of mutations in the middle of
this plastic syndrome so we applied high
score PCR to the quantitation of
mutations in the androgen in the yellow
dysplastic syndrome
operation with the banner Burton Rafael
bizarre as well as with Katherine little
from trans anomic so our collaborators
have demonstrated in this new england
journal paper what is the clinical
effect of point mutations in MDS mill of
dysplastic syndromes and they
demonstrated that there is a number of
genes like Lazarus in table 1 around x1
tp53 and sold for which the mutations
are prognostic and that includes endres
mutations so we did the following study
from a group of 295 and made of
dysplastic syndrome patient which with a
DNA first we applied conventional
techniques like multi and sequencing to
identify and rasmussen and 9 english
mutations were detected in this case by
doing this approaches multi in
sequencing can quantify mutations down
to ten to twenty percent 10 below ten
percent there are no mutations it's not
possible to identify the mutations so of
course we wanted to see if mutations
below that level still have clinical
significance and they correlate with
development of more aggressive
conditions for these patients we applied
standard code vision as opposed to ice
cold vision and these detected nine
additional mutations so now we had 18
mutations these mutations we're at the
level of point five to five percent
mutation frequency and if we apply the
ice cold visual the most sensitive
method that we have available if that
detected six additional mutations are
the levels of point one to point five
percent
so the mutation detecting were crippled
depending on how sensitive your method
of detection is art is clinically
significant so by observing and plotting
the level of the mutations with the
kaplan-meier curves for these patients
what you can see here what we saw is
that for certain mutation levels there
is some prognostic significance so if
there is no mutation as you can see here
in this fiscal or if the mutation is
very low the lowers that we detected
point 1 to point 2 percent there is no
difference in the kaplan-meier curves in
contrast when the mutation is high say
above two percent there is a clear
prognostic significance of those endless
mutations it's bad news to find an R Us
above 2% in this case and for mutations
at the level of point five to two
percent we saw an intermediate effect
and we demonstrated that mutations down
to this level are clearly differentiated
from the non mutation population so that
means that first it is important to have
very sensitive methods at least for MDS
syndrome that you can that allow you to
not miss mutations and second it is
important to quantitate and to place
threshold levels which potentially can
lead to a different term a therapeutic
action in certain cases on the next test
what we did is we wanted to see how
months old VCR could assistant the
detection of
station by next-generation sequencing
and here we are talking about amplicon
sequencing or targeted 3 sequencing not
for whole genome sequencing so amplicon
sequencing requires pcl so what you see
here is one does conventional pcr and
then pull the various pcr products or
one can do multiplex pcr of course then
you prepare library and then you can
apply the standard Illumina sequencing
as opposed to that we did call pcl to
enrich the mutations and follow the same
process and the results we see are
demonstrated here for mutations down to
two percent level one can see the
mutation easily with conventional pcr
followed by Illumina sequencing as the
mutation is at the level of about one
percent you can see that it is more
difficult to distinguish the mutation
from the noise which is generated from
the sequencer it's the sequencing
process itself so this is the limit when
we are doing conventional pcr followed
by sequencing and luminal sequencing in
contrast when we apply Kohl pcr we could
detect mutations down to point zero two
percent and that was still
distinguishable from where in the noise
level and importantly we only require 28
leads in this particular case to
identify the mutation so because of the
enrichment process prior to performing
sequencing one essentially makes
sequencing much more efficient because
then you don't sequence again and again
in Y type samples in order to find one
mutation in thousand wild types the
mutations have been enriched in advance
so that makes sequencing essentially
more efficient more effective we don't
waste worry agent sequencing again and
again wild type so we eventually
developed the next version of cold
vision which we term temperature
tolerant called vision which is
essentially a multiplex version of coal
pcr so for this version as long as
you're amplicons are within about one to
two degrees and difference interval in
their teams if there are melting
temperatures within one to two degrees
of each other we demonstrated that they
can be all Co amplified by a cold visual
and that you can enrich mutations on all
these amplicons at the same time and the
reason we did that is because targeted
resequencing starts with a multiplex pcr
step so we were interested to perform
cold pcr in multiplex fashion exactly
for this reason so what you see here a
50-50 amplicon tunnel on the top row we
have conventional pcr on the bottom row
we have the TT first call pc others we
dubbed it and you can see that mutations
are enriched compared to doing
conventional pcr followed by sequencing
simultaneously for many different things
like p53 GFR p53 action 6 and so on so
mutations were simultaneously enriched
on all of these genes and all of this
position to a different extent of course
because as we said in the beginning the
enrichment process depends to a certain
extent
from what mutation where the mutation is
in the sequence but in all cases we got
enrichment and here is the application
of the same temperature tolerant app
lower protein with the commercial
Huntley sec 192 amplicon tunnel with
address 700 cancer mutations and you see
the same type of of graphs here on the
top we have conventional pcr on the
bottom we have called PCR and you can
see that the mutations are enriched
simultaneously and by the details of
this work have been reported in clinical
chemistry 2015 recently and when we did
the serial dilution experiment combined
with Ion Torrent sequencing we
demonstrated the mutations down to 2002
5% of point zero one percent we are
still distinguishable from the noise by
doing this multiplex TT called PCR prior
to sequencing and of course plasma
circulating DNA is contains all the
jewels it is the entire genome so we
wanted to see if it is possible to apply
the method with plasma circulating DNA
and for and this is work in progress
essentially but what we did is we spiked
mutations into plasma from a normal
person at the level that one would
expect the mutation to be on a genome by
Gene abilities and we demonstrated that
the spike mutations can indeed be
enriched if one applies this typical pcr
over the entire genome by doing TT
ligation mediated PCR
the work is in progress so now we move
to an additional application of coal PCR
in order to preferentially enrich
hypermethylated sequences using coal
vision that's another application not
for mutilation but for hypermethylation
while we interested in this
hypermethylation of genomic regions is
something which is ubiquitous in cancer
so we don't we not only see
hypermethylation of promoters there is
also hypomethylation of several other
regions in in DNA in concert DNA like
bit sequences as well as other
regulatory elements and functional
elements hypermethylation is detected in
plasma circulating DNA and can serve as
a biomarker are they work by Denis Law
Group has demonstrated recently so we
observed that bisulphate converted DNA
which is used during methylation
detection what it does is generate c2d
trans vessels in DNA so a c 2 t
transversion in a hypo methylated DNA
essentially lowers the TM of those
sequences from sin 2t if a GC converts
to TA that lowers the TM of that region
of the DNA so we reasoned that
methylation specific or PCR can again be
employed to enrich hypermethylated
sequences on the basis of this TM
difference that is generated so here the
principles demonstrated again on the
left you see methylated sequences on the
left are unmethylated sequences
following bisulfite conversion the
methylated sequences remain as they are
why the hypermethylated sequence the
unmethylated sequences convert to you
and during subsequent pcr bc becomes T
so in other words it lowers them TM of
the sequence more than it lowers at them
during methylation methylated sequences
so methylation sensitive called PCR
essentially takes take advantage of this
process that the TM is reduced and when
the TM is reduced of a sequence we have
ways during called PCR as the other
described earlier to enrich the
hypermethylated lower TM sequences and
here is an example what you see at the
top is the sequencing of a mix of 0.05
percent very low amount of unmethylated
DNA diluted into methylated DNA and then
performing bisulfite sequencing of
course because it's only 0.05 percent
you don't expect to be able to sing the
unmethylated there however by performing
Cole pcl we can produce a very high
enrichment of the unmethylated portion
the original 0.05 person essentially
becomes almost a hundred percent the
methylated DNA does not amplify at all
in this case because the TM shift is
very big between methylated that are
methylated
as a result we can identify traces of
unmethylated DNA diluted within
methylated DNA so that's another
application of kultis er one can
potentially exploit this for many
sequences at the same time here is what
you saw is demonstration for a single
sequence the principle and that was
published them last year now we move to
improvement of another methodology which
is very common very popular high
resolution melting which is used for
known as well as unknown mutation
scanning this was one of our first
applications of cold pcr that we tried
so mutation scanning does not only
identify the mutation but it is telling
you that an amplicon does have a
mutation somewhere so it is giving you
less information but however it is rapid
and low-cost process it allows to focus
your resources for sequencing only on
the alternate sequences for sequences
that you already know there is a
mutation somewhere so that's the
usefulness of mutation scanning it is a
rapid pre-screening of DNA from Pleasant
of mutations high-resolution melting is
indeed the most commonly applied
methodology and in early work back in
2009 we demonstrated that cold pcr
instead of PCR produces a very high
enrichment that can help boost the
sensitivity of HRM by at least 20 folder
and allows subsequent sequencing of the
mutation something that there HRM
currently cannot help with you may
identify a mutation down to five ten
percent but then you cannot sequence if
you do Sanger sequencing but by using
coal PC
you essentially isolate the mutant and
you can sequence it so the two
methodologies cult hicieron data em
combine very well together and in some
very recent work we actually
demonstrated that DMSO during the Ada
and the HRM process will help atrium by
itself independent of code pcr and will
boost the sensitivity by a factor of
three to five fold and here is an
example on the left using no DMSO on the
Sun on the right you see seven percent
DMSO during the HRM process you will
notice that the mutations are becoming
bigger in the presence of DMSO so this
is this is independent of coal pcr but
of course we wanted to combine seven
percent DMSO class called this year and
what you see here on the bottom is a
combination of coal pcr with a time in
the presence of DMSO and one can get a
combined effect by in by improved
improvement of sensitivity by the coal
pcr plus the MSO at the end in a further
welcome which i won't go into details
now but this is because we have some
time pressure here as you can see where
the method can be applied to many
different genes and for every gene DMSO
has a different effect but in most cases
there is a three to five for the
improvement in sensitivity and finally
we concluded in this paper that we will
appear soon in clinical chemistry that
if one combines called PCR with DMSO
without much change of the existing
timers or any additional reagents one
can go down to mutation scanning of
point2 two-point-three percent now I
want to point out that this is without
using ice called PCR is called PCR is
still much more sensitive than that but
it requires you to have designed and
constructed the reference sequence with
Allah nails this development will see
here is without any additional
construction with a existing instruments
existing the agents so that's what we
highlight here that called PCR enables
increasing 8am sensitivity and
sequencing of low-level mutations with
very little investment and here are some
applications by many different groups
who apply Kohl pcr for the role for
their own applications crop improvement
drug-resistant mutation prenatal
diagnosis and so on circulating DNA very
recently by leading group improvement of
real-time PCR is another application and
I will not go into many details on this
that has been published some time ago as
well we demonstrated that if one applies
the principle of coal pcr together with
taqman technology one can increase the
sensitivity so at the top you see
conventional taqman genotyping of T 790
mutation for lung cancer you can only go
down to twelve percent mutant to
wild-type before you hit the white light
but with coal pcr you can go down two
point eight percent and if this is
combined with LNA based icicle pcr then
in real time one can get down 2.05 2.0
one percent mutations real-time pcr and
as you can see here this is fairly quant
that and finally we talk about another
recent application the application of
coal pcr in conjunction with droplet
digital PCR so digital PCR is a very
sensitive technique and very
quantitative that takes advantage of the
compartmentalization of of DNA molecules
for detection of mutations so droplet
digital PCR partitions the sample into
droplets that are either all wild-type
overall mutant and then it's droplet is
pcr-amplified and individually read by
the system and there is a number of
systems including Barada which is the
system we currently use rain dance as
well is another system as well as
digital PCR see use the digital PCR
systems that do not use droplets like
the fluid I'm system so for droplet
digital PCR currently one use a double
signal like one taqman problem with the
sequence of wild-type versus the same
prob with the sequence of the mutant so
the system is designed to detect normal
mutations at known positions of the
sequence so we wanted to see how can we
adapt droplet digital PCR for mutation
scanning now which means mutation can be
anywhere along the sequence so again I
repeat current digital PCR is is adapt
is adapted here not for non mutations
for but for unknown mutations over a
region for mutation scanning and
combined with Cole PCR
so how do we do that if one does
conventional digital PCR then what you
do is that you partition and every
molecule in different droplet and then
all of them are amplified both the
wild-type and mutant but if one
performed recycling indeed in coal pcr
format then only the droplets that
contained mutant are amplified while the
white type either does not amplify or
amplifies much less so we have mutant
biased pcr in this case moot mutant
buyers digital this year so the
principle we took advantage of is the
following we have two probes both of
which have the sequence of the wild-type
we do not design the probe to be
corresponding to a mutant at any
position the two probes have the
sequence of the wild-type one is labeled
with green thumb for example and the
other is labeled with a different
floraville so the sequence scanned for
mutations as you will see is the total
footprint under the probes if a probe is
20 base pairs 25 by sparrows it's then
sequence of 50 base pairs will be
scanned for mutations and how does this
happen we observe the ratio of the
signals this is the clue here the ratio
of the green to blue is indicative of
what is under the probe if one has a
mutation the signal will change the
signal ratio will change and here this
is very highlighted here if one uses the
two probes that match the white type
sequence
and what what will happen is that if you
have white type as the DNA that you are
screaming and not mutant both probes
will emit the fluorescence to an equal
extend both fun and hacks will be will
be appearing in you but if one has a
mutation what will happen is that one of
the taqman probes will bond will not
bind well because of them is months and
therefore there will be an imbalance
between the two signals so here is a
classical 2d graph like was that one
gets with them digital PCR on the bottom
access you have hex on the y-axis you
have fun in the ratio farm to hex is
what will we will monitor in this
application so when one has white eyed
DNA both Tuchman probes generate signal
to an equal extent in relative terms
equal extent and as a result one has a
double signal equal amount of thumb in
facts but if one has a hundred percent
mutant as you can see the signal my
grades in that Tuchman problem that has
wild-type underneath while the other
taqman probe which covers the mutation
does not give a strong signal so the
ratio of the signals the balance of the
two signals changes if there is a
mutation anywhere under the two probes
with fifty percent mutation again you
can see a partial migration with 25,000
mutation you can still see the effect
and with tempest and mutation 5%
mutation you can still detect so and
here
still have not applied Kohl TCR this is
dust conventional pcr so the principle
works anyway even if you do conventional
pcr conventional digital pcr the limit
is about two and a half percent mutant
as you can see and here we have plotted
the ratio of green to blue when when one
applies conventional digital PCR by
using the format i described with two
taqman probes corresponding to the
wild-type as you can see and as you
expect the wild-type has equal amounts
of green and blue right because both
probes operate time they bind to the
wild-type with good of anything so the
two probes are balanced the two signals
are balanced when one has a hundred
percent mutant one probe does not bind
well the other probe binds well and
generate signals and so on the limit is
about I would say five percent or ten
percent there is good reproducibility in
this ratio now look what happens to the
wild-type that you have here when you
apply called digital PCR the same thing
but in cold pcr cycling what happens is
that the wild-type essentially is
suppressed the signal from the wild-type
is suppressed ball for the green and the
blue as a result you can now see
imbalances in the signals even if you go
down to very low levels of the mutation
so called PCR gets the process to become
much more sensitive and here is some
application or with clinical samples
this work has been published in the JM
the internal of molecular diagnostics so
you can see more details there and
actually have the next two slides
running out of time here and so I will
go very fast we demonstrated the prince
by putting different mutations under the
two taqman probes we wanted to solve
that the principle candy Tecna tation
anywhere under Rita current probes
that's why we did that and we change the
p53 mutation in many different positions
and we demonstrated that in all cases
the signal ratio is perturbed from one
to one it changes either less than one
or above one depending on where the
mutation is yes so this is what is
highlighted in these lights so one can
envision that more than one tockman
probes like three probes or four probes
can be used with multicolored digital
PCR machines which unfortunately are not
yet widely available but the principle
is exactly the same the ratio of green
to blue to yellow would be used for
detection of mutations anywhere under
the sequence so to summarize they called
digital PCR is a simple principle that
can be applied with existing data pcr
technology the aim in this particular
application is not to improve the
sensitivity the limit because digital
PCR already is excellent it can go down
to 0.01 percent but to enable digital
mutation scanning for target amplicons
it which is not currently available with
the existing digital pcr embodiments and
two or more fluorescent probes define
the food preform mutations coming and I
will finish with this thank you for your
attention and I would like to
acknowledge my collaborators and the
people at my lab that have done the hard
work thank you very much for your
attention
thank you Mike for bringing that
information to us excellent presentation
we're just going to remind the audience
questions can be submitted in green Q&A
button and the lower left of the
presentation window will get to as many
as we can we do actually have a couple
in there right now oh one of our
audience members wants to know why is
the mutation that were detected why is
it tripled I'm not sure I follow why is
why is the mutation Tippett which which
I don't know which slide you mean we can
we can move on to the next question and
we'll be trying to follow up that
audience member our next question could
you say a couple of words about the
primer design for the whole PCR is it
the same as for the regular pcr okay
Brenda yes ok so I hope you can hear me
now so the primer design is pretty much
the same except that the you have to
make sure that the TM of the primer is
not too high so you cannot design a
primer but has a TM of about 70 degrees
and expect to do the cross hybridization
that one does during coal picea because
then the primers will bind and extend
even at 70 degrees and to make this more
clear in the second type of coal pcr we
do a cross hybridization step where we
assume that the primer does not bind
otherwise the principle does not work so
if your primer has a high TM it will
bind and it will spoil the enrichment
so other than that the Primus for called
PCR do not differ from the primers that
one uses for pcr so in many cases you
can adapt your existing primers to
perform cold vision by simply changing
the protocol that we use on your PCR
machine having said that I would like to
point out that your PCR machine has to
be a high quality so good
reproducibility and very little
variation of a temperature from well to
well your temperature variation has to
be less than point about point three
degrees from well too well many pcr
machines can go down to below point one
percent but there are some pcr machines
that have variations thanks very much
that is all the time we have the
questions I just want to pass it back to
dr. mario goes for any of his last final
comments or information vice for our
audience yes thank you very much for
your attention I'm happy to reply by
email to any future question so if you
try called PCR and you find them any
difficulties if you have any questions
how to use it please feel free to email
good luck thank you again dr. Melfi are
those for that good information for our
audience want to let our audience know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through March of 2016
you'll be receiving an email from lab
roots to let you know when it's
available for replay we would invite you
to forward that email to any of your
colleagues who might have missed today's
live event thank you again for logging
on and being part of this broadcast we
hope to see you again why
you